okay now one other thing i want to
separate this clip out from yesterday's
press briefing
because it really boggles the mind how
ignorant and clueless
donald trump still is on the basics of
coronavirus
during yesterday's press briefing donald
trump asked
is there a way to separate the flu and
coronavirus
can we distinguish if someone has the
flu
from someone who has coronavirus it's
almost like
trump hasn't spent the last six months
talking about
testing coronavirus testing coronavirus
tests
which tell you whether you have
coronavirus
or not this is inconceivable
that this is a question we're still
getting from trump in september
you see what's happening in europe
however they have a very big spike
countries that we thought were doing
well aren't doing well they had some
very big spikes very a very big surge
months ago we increased our nation's
procurement
of the flu vaccine by 66 percent and we
ask americans to go get their annual flu
shot as early as possible
it's possible i would imagine uh scott
that
the flu can get mixed up with the virus
and
people can think it's the virus when
actually it's another flu season coming
on
i don't know it's uh i hope they can
keep them separate can they keep them
separate
we hope so i definitely will it's
going to be a very interesting time but
we have a flu season coming up we've had
some flu seasons which are
really massive over the years scott do
we have a way of separating a flu case
and a coronavirus case
and even more bizarre i mean it's a gong
show scott atlas bizarrely says
i hope we do and donald trump says i
don't think we do
he spent the last six to seven months
talking about coronavirus tests
testing how many tests how fast are the
tests
he says it all the time when you test
you find cases
that's how you separate a coronavirus
case from something else we have a test
for the flu
which tells us if someone has the flu we
have a test for coronavirus
which tells us if someone has
coronavirus how does the president of
the united states not know that at this
point it
it's mind-blowing inconceivable
ignorance and
and maybe more important well not more
importantly but
equally interesting is that this is
probably a peak behind the curtain
of how people deal with trump behind the
scenes the normal response if someone
says
hey can we tell the difference between
coronavirus and the flu a normal
response would be absolutely
we have tests for the flu and we have
tests for coronavirus no problem
this is how it works scott atlas instead
says i hope that we can
what and my sense is that this is how it
works behind the scenes frequently we
wonder
trump's been mispronouncing convalescent
plasma
as convalescent plasma for months how
has no one just said oh
you know mr press sir as trump likes to
say sir
it's plasma apparently trump loses his
mind when people do that
we wonder why does trump keep saying the
1917 flu
it's the 1918 flu why has no one gone up
to him and said
it's 1918 not 1917. well scott atlas's
response tells us why
people are either afraid of trump or
they've decided
they can't correct him or it's pointless
to correct him or whatever
but that is probably the explanation
that you saw there
and it's scary because there is no error
correcting mechanism
in the same way that scott atlas doesn't
just say yes of course
we have flu tests and coronavirus tests
we have to believe
that behind the scenes you see a similar
lack of pushback
on foreign policy on economic policy on
everything
horrifying horrifying and frightening
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches and they're giving you up to
30 percent off everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're looking for an awesome way to
update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wristwatch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video